foreign
hello there are you playing multiverses
the platform fighter that mushes
together so many Warner Brothers
properties that Bugs Bunny can fight
Arya Stark the plan for this video is to
go over as many Secrets Easter eggs
awesome details and references to other
media as we can and answer such
questions as why is there a golden
Superman in the game you ready let's do
this first things first did you know
that there is a mature language toggle
in the settings by flicking this it will
allow some characters to say a few
fruity things especially Harley that
girl has a filthy mouth
Batman can also say ass computer log
that one under very badass this is a big
step forward for the Caped Crusader with
Rick and Morty joining the game soon
this mature filter may be the only way
to play but you've got to ask your
parents first the game demands it when
the internet saw Shaggy's Ultra Instinct
Powers we all assumed rightly that it's
a Dragon Ball reference Shaggy is going
Super Saiyan well it turns out Shaggy
has always had this power for real it
was first officially seen in the
introduction of Mortal Kombat Legends
check it out
over here man
[Music]
another Dragon Ball reference can be
heard when Shaggy and Batman face off
Batman can say this
those rumors about his power level are
true
this is a subtle not to when Goku's
power level was scanned Vegeta what did
you say his power level is
it's over 9 000. this isn't the only
reference to find when Shaggy and Batman
meet up Shaggy can say this hey Batman
didn't we like team up one time dude
Batman we're friends remember it turns
out as far back as the 1970s Scooby-Doo
and friends have been teaming up with
The Capes Crusader to capture notorious
criminals from Gotham City by The Joker
and the Penguin any Game of Thrones fans
in the house you'll notice that when
Arya Stark gets a ring out she'll drop a
pie this in fact is far darker than it
seems because in that pie are some of
the people she's killed in Game of
Thrones yeah who said this was a kid's
game when Batman and Arya meet up they
share many lines most notably is
Batman's inability to get her name right
Arya Arya Arya it never gets easier Arya
he says Arya instead of Arya which isn't
a big deal to many people but back when
Game of Thrones was running this would
annoy the heck out of all the super fans
a girl is of Winterfell over to the
first ever battle pass a bunch of items
to unlock both free and paid it turns
out that Tier 15 holds a secret
reference in Adventure Time Finn is
learning about the levels of dating such
as touching hard for the first time
we've all been there he asks about tier
15. look look let me explain some junk
about dating right now you're at tier
one which is hugging what about tier 15.
stay away from that
do not do tier 15. so we now know that
Tier 15 of dating has something to do
with a cat and some pajamas in fact
let's stick with alternative skins for a
moment because some have cool little
backstories Jake becomes cake a cat
version of Jake from that Time Adventure
Time gender swapped Finn to make Fiona
and also switch Jake into a female cat
ice cream why your eyes predatoring on
dudes another alternative skin is the
golden Superman variant 1 million
outside of the game it's also known as
Superman Prime this one goes hard after
outliving all his family here on Earth
this version of Clark Kent left our Rock
and spent 15 000 years in the sun yeah
they're literally the big ball of fire
in this guy he became a god a very shiny
golden one I think it looks amazing but
my friends still call it you're in
Superman rip Shaggy's first variant is
actually a completely different
character it's not Shaggy in a smoking
jacket it's Uncle shagsworthy who has
their own lines of dialogue and in the
UK if someone is Shag worthy it means
something very different I'll let people
in the comments explain that one baby
yeah Wonder Woman's bloodline attire is
taken from the 2019 movie and this
moment when she gets a wardrobe update
and the code name Wonder Woman what do
you think Steven Universe's Garnet has
this attire first fusion and it's a nod
to this scene where Ruby and Sapphire
meld into one preventing their demise
[Music]
oh
what this also ties into her defeat
screen when all that is Left Behind are
two gems on the floor Tom and Jerry get
to become Pirates this look was first
seen on Tom in the shiver Me Whiskers
episode where at the end of the show
Jerry became the shim's captain ggs if
you knew that the other variant skins at
this point are summer themed are a
little bit obvious like Harley and
Batman's alts that are taken from the
Animated Series Harley Quinn dresses as
a harlequin no less it's been noted that
Harley's first emote in which he stands
in an acrobatic Landing pose is taken
from the souls Bond games and the
infamous praised the sun emote I'm not
too sure about that but I quite like it
we all know that Taz wants to eat
absolutely everything to prepare for
that he'll try to season his enemies
with salt and pepper so technically he's
assaulting them sorry about that Taz
does have a few lines from his history
though following a ring out he can say
this
why for you bury me in the cocoa ground
which comes from this age-old animation
what for you bury me in the cold cold
ground well you know if you're playing
as Velma and crawl around hunting for
her glasses the entire screen will lose
focus just slightly emulating how bad
her eyesight is without her specks on
pretty cool touch LeBron's moveset has
been taken from his NBA career but one
stands out more than any other this
you'll probably already remember the
meme of this going around the internet
in 2018 but if you don't it was taken
from the first game of the NBA Finals
when in the last moment James's teammate
effectively lost the game for them and
LeBron wasn't very happy at all that
birth the meme and now it's in the game
maybe one day this censored swear word
here will be uncensored with the machar
filter off how often do you take your
hands off the controller to check out
idle animations in video games most of
them in Rumble verses aren't anything to
shout about but there are a few pretty
cool ones Garnet will briefly take off
her Shades to show she has three eyes
I'd never seen Steven Universe so I was
pretty shocked when I saw this Batman
becomes the Sinister outline from the
animated show looks great and the best
of all Tom and Jerry if Tom and Jerry
stand completely still long enough Tom
will finally catch that rodent after 82
years of trying all he had to do was
stop chasing that Mouse okay let's move
on to move sets most have General combos
inspired by their Origins like Wonder
Woman and the move she has in the movie
definite direct inspiration some
characters though have really detailed
moves from their subject matter for
example when playing as Finn after
collecting 1 000 coins you'll be able to
bring out [ __ ] and his devastating [ __ ]
chop it's absolutely brutal Adventure
Time fam will already know about this
scene from the TV show but for everyone
else check it out
if this were a real Attack you're dead
he's right though it's devastating
[Music]
Bugs Bunny can get his mitts on an Acme
crate and bring out a ton of weapons
from other franchises he can pull out a
me seeks box from Rick and Morty's
Universe complete with unlimited Mr
meeseeks who have a bit of law to keep
in mind this is a me6 box you press this
you make a request all done wow and then
it stops existing after completing their
task in life they immediately stop
existing books can also take out a
banana Guard from Adventure Time who
runs mindlessly into battle complete
with a spear
and speaking of Adventure Time Jake can
shapeshift unlimitedly on the
battlefield leading to some strange
references from the TV show so let's try
and break a few down becoming a horse
and charging across the screen is from
the time he became the most trusty Steed
oh come on
come on you didn't even
try horses are hard
how's that
he can become a house a boat a car all
three of these again from the show
replicated perfectly but the one that'll
stick with you is how Finn enters the
car prepare for nightmares
The Iron Giant is the character with the
most moves taken from a movie and it's
truly impressive I didn't know many of
these so I need to thank glickstick for
locating each of these I'll link their
channel in the description below the
move which beats up and then sits on a
car is taken from this scene where the
Iron Giant is desperately trying to turn
off a car alarm in the middle of the
night that car returns for a spinning
attack and in the movie The Giant is
helping a young boy live out a flying
fantasy I kinda want to watch the movie
now the running bomb attack is from The
Iron Giant swimming scene
and of course the afterburners under his
feet are a reference too which also
leads to an uppercut as The Iron Giant
pretends to be Superman
[Music]
even his s plate turn and his sitting
animation after losing are directly
taken perfectly from the movie the
attention to detail is mind-blowing
finding all this out makes me want to
give Iron Giant another go
and finally back to Batman and the bat
cave in here are four Easter eggs to
look out for the first two are potential
additions to the roster take a look at
the computer screen in the background
here we have the Joker and it looks to
be the Mark Hamill version that's my cue
and as we all know all the voices in the
game are performed by the real artists
from their TV or film outings but
there's bigger news than that look
around and you'll see the face of Alfred
the hero we all meet and yeah there's
Catwoman 2 I suppose seriously though a
few things down here don't look like
they belong and they've been here for
decades namely a giant coin and a T-Rex
nerdsync's YouTube channel broke this
down for me it turns out that the T-Rex
is from a dinosaur theme park in which
Batman and Robin were tasked with
surviving for 30 hours against
animatronic dinosaurs and Neanderthals
how insane does that sound and a giant
Penny on the other hand is from a bad
guy called the penny plunderer who used
it like a trojan horse to sneak into an
exhibit to steal everything and in the
end that coin fell down directly on the
bad guy and squished him to death and
now it's in the bat cave hopefully they
they cleaned it first multiverses
promises to have years of Secrets Easter
eggs references and cool details to look
out for so expect me back each and every
season with more you may have missed
like this Green Lantern's Lantern it's
in the trailer from months ago did
anybody notice that I guess we wait for
how to arrive if you spot any more
Easter egg Secrets or really cool
details in multiverses please let me
know in the comments I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time foreign